right um the next talk uh is by one of
our simon's berkeley postdoctoral
fellows william huzza will tell us about
pseudorandom generators and small space
d dynamism
thanks
uh yeah so i'm william hi everybody uh
this is my second year as a postdoc here
and yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna talk to you
a little bit about pseudorandomness
okay so
a pseudorandom generator is a function
that stretches a short truly random seed
out to a long pseudorandom string
and what we mean by that is that for
every boolean function f in some class
script f
the acceptance probability of f is
approximately the same whether you plug
in truly random bits or you plug in
pseudorandom bits that you get from the
generator
okay
now uh traditionally the class script f
that people have been most interested in
maybe is where you take script f to be
like everything that can be computed in
polynomial time
right pseudorandom generators that fool
all polynomial time computations and
that can themselves be computed in
polynomial time are important and useful
for cryptography and deranimization and
all sorts of other things
but the only trouble with such tutorial
generators is that we don't know whether
they exist
right
it seems to be extremely difficult to
design pseudorandom generators that fool
all polynomial time computations uh and
so for the time being we should probably
consider them to be out of reach
um and so what i think is is more
interesting is to consider a class
script f that's like a much more
restricted model of computation okay a
weaker model
because that way we can actually prove
something we can actually design
pseudorandom generators that work
so here's like a toy example that that
hopefully can clarify the idea
we could take script f to be the class
of all depth two decision trees
okay
here's a pseudo random generator that
stretches two bits to three bits and
fools this model
the generator is right there g of x y is
x and then y and then the xor of x and y
right
so these three bits x y and the xor
that's like the traditional example of
three random variables that are pairwise
independent but not mutually independent
right and so because they're pairwise
independent uh they fool
uh and any depth to decision tree a
decision tree that looks at just two
bits
so hopefully that like clarifies the
paradigm but of course really we would
like to fool richer and more interesting
models of computation than just this
like depth two decision trees on three
input bits
um so to give you a few examples
of my own research with collaborators
i've designed pseudorandom generators
that fool i think interesting models of
computation things like uh bounded depth
threshold circuits or like bounded depth
read once formulas or certain types of
branching programs
and yeah i mean i want to emphasize that
in every case like these pseudorandom
generators are are unconditional we
don't rely on any unproven mathematical
assumptions
going forward
yeah sure
yes that's right
uh so going forward some of the
remaining challenges for pseudorandom
generator designers are to design better
pseudorandom generators that fool space
bounded computation
um and to design better pseudorandom
generators that fuel various types of
bounded depth circuits
i should probably say something about
like you know what's the point of all
this
i guess the most basic reason to design
pseudorandom generators is because we
want to think of random bits as like a
computational resource kind of like time
or space okay so just like a faster
algorithm is better than a slower
algorithm
similarly an algorithm that uses less
randomness is better than an algorithm
that uses more randomness right and best
of all is a completely deterministic
algorithm an algorithm that uses zero
random bits right and pseudorandom
generators are
are can be useful for designing
deterministic algorithms too
because basically the trick is that you
can exhaustively try all seeds to the
pseudorandom generator
ironically pseudorandom generators also
sometimes have applications to the
design of randomized algorithms um
and lastly probably the most important
application application of pseudorandom
generators is that every time we design
a pseudorandom generator that fools some
model of computation f
that teaches us you know something about
that model f it gives us insights into
the limits and abilities of that model f
because a pseudorandom generator is
basically like a particularly high
quality type of lower bound okay it's
giving an example of some task something
that this model of computation like
cannot understand at all
okay actually i want to go back to this
the second point here this topic of
de-randomizing algorithms
um this has been like a traditional goal
in complexity theory for a long time
right we would like to understand the
role of randomness in computation we
would like to take randomized algorithms
and convert them into deterministic
algorithms
while being you know while retaining
efficiency by other measures such as
space complexity
okay so some some terminology um bp
space s
is uh the class of all languages that
can be decided by randomized algorithms
using of s bits of space okay
the the commonly believed conjecture in
complexity theory is that bp space s
coincides with deterministic space s
okay so this conjecture is saying that
randomness is not actually necessary for
space efficient computation so you can
feel free to throw all your fair coins
into the trash game
um i think this is a really nice uh
conjecture a really nice problem
um i think first of all it's like it's
appealing in sort of a quasi
quasi-philosophical way much like other
topics in complexity theory like the p
versus np problem right it seems to be
like saying something very fundamental
about about the power of randomness
about these these these resources
um
but another thing that i find appealing
about this problem that maybe sets it
apart from like p versus np is that uh
there has actually been quite a lot of
successful progress on this problem
um we have a lot of uh theorems that
that say you know some kind of
interesting derandomization of
space-bounded computation uh even if
they don't you know fully fully prove
this conjecture
so just to give you a couple of examples
from my own research
um
today like the state of the art
deranimization of of bp space s says
that you know if you can if you have a
randomized algorithm that uses s bits of
space then we can simulate it
deterministically using
o of s to the three halves over square
root log s
bits of space okay and this is like you
know just barely better than uh you know
what was proven back in the 90s but but
maybe the main point is that it's it's
uh you know we have some bound right
it's it's it's uh something that's
non-trivial we actually can prove some
type of unconditional deer randomization
another example from my own work is that
suppose you can design some randomized
algorithm
that simultaneously uses a small amount
of space and a small amount of time okay
maybe it's like log space quasi-linear
time
then we can get a deterministic
algorithm for that problem that still
runs in logarithmic space
uh with the caveat that occasionally
gives the wrong answer it it might give
the wrong answer on some small fraction
of inputs of each plane
so to try to give you like a a taste of
the techniques that go into
you know these works like how do you get
started proving some kind of dear
randomization let me tell you like some
of the ideas behind this second theorem
um so the first idea uh goes back to
work by goldrich and viggerson which is
um if we're only if we're willing to
settle for a typically correct
organization we're okay with getting a
wrong answer on a few inputs then we can
think of the input as being selected at
random and we're trying to succeed with
high probability right and if the input
is selected at random then great that
right there is like a source of random
bits that we can try to use to simulate
this randomized algorithm
the difficulty with with you know making
that work is that well i mean when when
a randomized algorithm is designed we
assume that the input and the random
bits are independent right and so if we
try to use the input as a source of
random bits then we're introducing some
troublesome correlations
the approach for breaking those
correlations
um was basically to uh to use part of
the input as a source of random bits
while the algorithm is looking somewhere
else
uh with the intuition being like this
way the stuff that we're feeding in as
random bits the algorithm is more or
less independent of everything that the
algorithm is currently thinking about
and of course some additional ideas
aren't necessary to make this approach
make any sense but it turns out that you
know it can be made to work
you have a question yeah so this type of
idea is saying this
and the inputs are valid anyway
in some sense
you're choosing rather
yeah yeah so the question was was
whether uh this sort of like using the
input as a source of random bits uh does
that idea have applications in like
machine learning types of settings where
you know we're thinking of the input as
being selected from some distribution
anyway i mean it's standard in machine
learning that we're okay with getting
the wrong answer occasionally
yeah that's a great question i don't i'm
not aware of any work uh that does that
type of thing you know there there are
you know quite a few you know wilbrake
and vanderson's work was uh spawned
quite a lot of follow-up but all the
work that i'm aware of is more like in a
complex a theoretic setting uh but
that's a good question i i don't
know okay
um
so anyway i just wanted to say really
quickly like all right so that was an
example of like a partial
de-randomization of space-mounted
computation
uh but i want to emphasize that like
there are no barriers known there's no
particular reason you know there's
nothing known that's stopping us from
proving a full de-randomization of
space-bounded computations so you know
i'd love to chat with you about it if
you're interested in working on this
problem with me or you know maybe some
easier problems along the way
um okay and just really quickly i should
say like uh i mean
i i besides like pseudorandomness and
deranimization more generally what i'm
interested in is like complexity theory
uh so for example some of my recent work
is about like circuit lower bounds
so that's other stuff that you could
talk to me if you want so thanks for
listening
side channel attacks
which was in the surrounding number
generation so suppose part of your uh
seed leaks yeah and then can you still
say something about the outcome so is
that a little bit related because you're
saying that
uh
[Music]
it doesn't work they are using one part
yeah
it is absolutely related
yeah yeah so it turns out uh so this
isn't what goldrick and victorson did
but there were some of the follow-up
work uh was showing that
if you have like a pseudorandom
generator with this like seed extending
property so like the first thing that
the generator outputs is the seed and
then it outputs a bunch of other stuff
then those pseudorandom generators can
imply typically correct your
randomizations uh and it's for like the
sort of reasons that you're saying like
we want pseudorandomness that's still
pseudorandom even if you know the seed
part of it yeah yeah
thanks thanks for the great talk i
really enjoyed it i had a very quick
question so you said that the definition
of the pseudomonas is that the
probabilities of it actually being
uniform and the probability of being
output by the algorithm are essentially
the same what does it mean to be sort of
how how how close would they have to be
to be
does that make sense yeah yeah like yeah
i just put some approximately equal sign
right yeah yeah so i mean in general you
know we care about the error parameter
epsilon
um and so i guess for like this space
bounded deer randomization problem uh
for you know general like complexity
theoretical randomization it's really
fine if the error is just some small
constant like let's say 0.1
because you know if we're trying to
derandomize some randomized algorithm
we could first
improve the randomized algorithm to have
a low
error probability
right and if it has a low error
probability
then when you use a pseudo-random
generator instead of true random bits
that is low error probability just you
know it increases by maybe
one percent or whatever
but there are other contexts where it
matters about you know getting a very
small error for a pseudonym generator
and so that's absolutely like you know
part of what we care about in this
research
okay maybe we'll have the next speaker
set up if there's one more quick
question
thanks william
[Applause]